ぺち
いきなりこんな映像から始まってしまい申し訳ございません
はじめしゃちょーです
この動画はですねあの毛、毛とか、毛っ毛とか
男の裸とか
ちょっとグロいのうわ〜ちょっと無理だー、あたし無理よーみたいな人は
あのここでやめておいてください
というわけで皆んな　今日は主に男性諸君
君たちに話しておきたい
ってか参考にしてほしい
まぁいつからだろう　俺も気づいた頃には
すでにそっち側の人間だった
そう俺たち男は大人になるにつれて
毛！毛について悩まさるでしょう
そこの君もそうじゃないか？
いや俺の記憶が…
ってかわき毛も薄いんすよ実は
僕わき毛もそもそも薄いんですけど
いやーでも早い人はもうね中学校から始まっちゃってるし
高校でも結構もう毛深すぎてもうやばい人もいたし
僕はですねその毛の猛威に襲われたのが
えーハタチになってからだったんですよ
ハタチになってから急にヒゲがブワッて生えだしたり
なんか体毛がめっちゃ毛深くなったりして
あぁ、こうやって人はおっさんになっていくんだなぁ
って感じで思っていたんですけども
今は　男でも　脱毛する時代なんです
そう思って俺はハタチの時に
なけなしの金を使って脱毛に行ったが…
ダサいだろう　だが…
もうね仕方ないんすよ　痛いもん
だって毛って生えるものでしょ？
その生えてくるものを生えてこなくってさせるってことは
どんだけ毛苦しい思いしてんだよっていう
もう結局毛を痛めつけるしかないんで
やっぱ痛さは仕方ないんでそこを堪えていくしかないんで
まぁ一つの参考例としてみんなには見ててほしい
結局ねこのヒゲとか剃ると肌が痛むんで
僕顔的に多分ヒゲが似合わないんで
それだったら無くしておいた方がいいんじゃねぇか
まぁ色んな要因があって僕は今回
全部の毛の脱毛に行って来ます
いやー聞いてくださいよ色んな理由があるんですよ
いつも行ってるクリニックのお姉さんが
VIOやる？って言われて
え？VIOってなに？って思ったんですけど
VIOっていうのは全身とは別のデリケートゾーンのことですね
隠部の周りの毛
みたいなこと言われて
ってことでやることになりました
くそっ
結局どこを脱毛するにもレーザー当たるんで痛いんですけど
チン毛股毛ケツ毛がほんとに一番痛いらしいです
なんで今回は僕がもうこの　ぺち
ぺち　この身を持って
ヒゲも体全身も
もうそのチン毛股毛ケツ毛も全部やるんで
まぁどこがどれくらい痛いかっていうのは
もう僕の表情から見てわかると思うんで
それを今回皆さんにお伝えしようと思います
レーザー脱毛の参考にしてください
っていうわけでもう明日レーザー脱毛行ってくるんですけども
レーザー脱毛の前にしなきゃいけないことが一つありまして
全身の毛を剃ります
決してそんなバカみたいに濃いわけじゃないんですよね僕も
だってこういう毛も剃らないと効果がないんで
まぁこういうとこっすよねこういう毛
こういう細かい毛とかも全部剃っていきます
もちろんチン毛もな！
全身の毛全部剃ったらどれくらい毛が溜まんのか
っていうのをちょっとやってみたいと思います
僕ですね体の毛結構濃いんすよ
いや剛毛っていうわけじゃないんですけども
まぁ人並みに濃いっす
ってか普通に濃いっす
なんか薄いっぽく見えるんですけども全然そんなことなくて
結局何回か脱毛行って今があるんで
全然濃いんで毛が濃い男性の皆さん安心してください
僕も一緒です
じゃ全部剃ってきまーす
腕からやろっか
えー体の毛を全部剃るのに3時間半かかりました
全然グロいんでそんなに見なくていいと思うんですけども
大体全部剃るとこれぐらいの毛の量になります
まぁ子犬1匹ぐらいの毛は刈れたと思います
まぁもう基本的に腕はツルツル
足もスベスベでございます
ってかまずケツ毛なんて剃ったこともないし見たこともないんでなんか危なかったっす
なんかすごい痒いです
この後病院に行って来ます　では
はぁ〜
だいち）いやマジでビビってんじゃないですかｗｗ
はじめ）いやまじで怖いんだよね
クリニックの方）とりあえず1回目2回目ぐらいだったらあのー全部なくなってるってことはないんで
はじめ）はい、お願いします
だいち）はははｗｗｗ
クリニックの方）じゃあ裏面できる範囲でやっちゃいますね
はじめ）はい、お願いしまーす
クリニックの方）よろしくお願いします
はじめ）はい！お願いしまーす
だいち）お願いしまーす
クリニックの方）はいじゃいきまーす
はじめ）はい
クリニックの方）はい
クリニックの方）できる限り目つぶっといてくださいね
はじめ）はーい
というわけで今から肛門のレーザー脱毛です
クリニックの方）いきます
はじめ）はいお願いしまーす
はじめ）待ってくださいねちょっと待ってください
はじめ）ちょっと心の準備を
はじめ）ボール握ってればはい
はじめ）あ"あ"あ"なるほどそういう感じかOKです
はじめ）把握しましたいけます
はじめ）あーなるほどなるほどそういう感じか
はじめ）く"う"う"う"う"う"く"う"う"う"う"う"う"う"
はじめ）う"わ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"
はじめ）い"い"た"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"
はじめ）あっこえ、山越えました
だいち）すんごい汗がｗ
隠毛のレーザー脱毛にいってきます
はじめ）はぁ〜い〜
はじめ）あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"
はじめ）なるほどなるほどOKですOKです把握しました
クリニックの方）はい
はじめ）いけます
クリニックの方）いけます？
はじめ）まぁまぁまだまだまだ、まだここは大丈夫です
はじめ）う"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"
はじめ）経験上感覚があります
はじめ）ありがとうございますっ
はじめ）はいでは続いてヒゲです
はじめ）お願いします
はじめ）よっしゃーありがとうございます
はじめ）どうだった？
だいち）音がもう
はじめ）ばち、ばちばちいうもんね
はじめ）ばちばちしてたと思うんすけどあんまり痛くないんですよ
はじめ）鼻下はさすがにちょっとびくってなるけど
はじめ）耐えれる耐えれる
はじめ）終わりました
はじめ）もう本当の全身ですよねこれが
クリニックの方）これ本当の全身です
はじめ）よっしゃーありがとうございました
はじめ）ました〜
はじめ）終わったぜー
だいち）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）え？
だいち）周りｗｗｗ
はじめ）ははｗｗここ？
はい、というわけでレーザー脱毛行ってきました
うう(；ω；)
まぁ痛いっていうのもそもそも僕はね
出力実は最大マックスでやってるんで
それはもちろん痛いです
でもさ効果が強いんだったら僕は別に痛くてもいいかなと思ってる派の人間なんで
結構まじで限界レベルで痛かったんすけど頑張りました
レーザーあてた部分の毛っていうのがなんか…
1週間か2週間ぐらい経ったら
なんかポロポロって落ちてくるらしいので
そしたら綺麗な肌ができてくるって感じでございます
いやー待って毛なくて変
俺別にここの毛無くなって欲しいって思ってるわけじゃないんで
程よく薄くなればいいかなぐらいだと思います
まぁヒゲは本当に剃るのがめんどくさいし
もしなんかそういう毛とか気になってる方がいたら
こんな感じだよっていうのがわかってくれればよかったです
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング　穏やかVer.】